all right it's become a regular feature
here which doesn't belong and why and
look at the top five scoring defenses in
the national football league the ravens
hey
they can handle anybody except the
chiefs they'll probably get another
chance to do so in
the postseason so let's start on that
note which doesn't belong and why three
teams allowing
fewer than 20 points per game ravens
colts and rams peter which doesn't
belong and why
you know i got to say the colts because
i got
i've got to see them have the staying
power over the course of the season
because i believe in the impact players
um you know of the other teams more than
i believe in the impact players
of the colts but that's the great thing
about a 16 game
season everything gets fleshed out
over time you know first of all nobody's
stopping aaron donald we know that
okay and other than the kansas city
chiefs
nobody is fake or the ravens kryptonite
as lamar jackson says
but not just on offense but on defense
as well
right now to me i've got to see more
in more games out of the indianapolis
colts
to sort of break into that uh you know
to really be a top three defense in the
league
see i'm gonna say the rams for a very
simple reason their four wins have come
against the four teams of the nfc
east so it really isn't a surprise when
you give up
nine to the giants and ten to washington
teams that have offenses that aren't
very good
it makes it easier to have a pretty good
defense we'll see how they do once they
start playing some of these teams
with higher powered offenses they give
up 35 to the bills when they faced them
a few weeks ago
all right top three quarterbacks in
interceptions
carson wentz kirk cousins and kyler
murray which doesn't belong and why
i would say carson wentz because carson
wentz i believe is in
is in a slump i think that
the other two quarterbacks are probably
just going to throw some interceptions
you know we've seen it kirk cousins in
his career he throws some interceptions
kyler murray as of now right now
is a guy who's going to throw it to the
other team
but to me i think carson wentz
if you believe as i do that he is
fixable
and all he is is in the first five games
of this year and he's playing a little
better now
that he's in a slump i don't think he's
going to be throwing interceptions at
this rate
uh in that he's thrown in the first
third of the season
in the last third of the season i'm
going to say kyler murray just because i
don't care how many interceptions he
throws he's still
electric he's fun to watch it's edge of
the seat every time he gets the ball
and i can't wait to see kyler murray and
the arizona cardinals in the real monday
night football game this week not the
extra one
with the chiefs and the bills although
the extra one's probably a better game
i'm excited
for the reality that kyler murray's
getting a national platform
getting a chance to show everyone what
he can do and i think the more the
people see him the more they appreciate
him so i can deal with
interceptions from time to time because
he can do so many other things so well
all right last one the top three rushers
which doesn't belong and why dalvin cook
josh jacobs derek henry
i mean i could see any one of these
three
basically winning the rushing title i'll
say the one that doesn't belong
is derek henry because when he gets
ahead of steam
nobody's tackling him you know i don't
care you know
he he's just so powerful and i mean he
doesn't belong
in a good way um you know he's so
difficult once he gets in the open field
i mean the josh norman play is just
gonna be unfortunately on josh norman's
uh anti-highlight reel forever
and but but listen if you go back
through his nfl career
you'll see ten of those not exactly that
glaring maybe
with with derek henry but he is just so
incredibly strong uh that i don't think
there's
anybody in the game like him right now
as a running back
you could probably do some highlights of
business decisions people have made like
darrell rivas like earl thomas
avoiding the josh norman treatment i'm
going to say
dalvin cook because for me to be a high
end running back over the
long haul you got to be durable and
healthy and that's been the big flaw for
dalvin cook
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights
from nbc sports